defense and security analyst Professor
Michael Clark Michael good to see you
and the fighting has been going on
around back but for some time now Yen
stoltenberg referring to it as the fact
that you know it could be a pivotal
point in this war if it falls why is
that yes I mean this things are getting
critical now the uh the Russians or the
Wagner group are into the center of
bakmut they're as far as the river but
the bakrutika river runs right through
the middle of the city if they tried to
cross the river and the ukrainians tried
to defend it then the Russians will have
a problem crossing a river in the middle
of a city is never easy now the
ukrainians may not try to defend it more
importantly the Russians are moving in
to try to block the access roads and the
one that matters is this the 504 or the
0504 is the local number for it to uh
and that road is the only route out
which the ukrainians can take and that
road is already under artillery fire so
it's already a gauntlet they have to run
to get in and out if the Russians can
actually break that link then the
ukrainians will have to withdraw they
can't allow themselves to be surrounded
but the problem for the Russians then
what you know Mr stoltenberg said this
should not be allowed to be a turning
point and it won't be politically
they've got to manage the loss of
banknote if they lose it but militarily
it doesn't do the Russians any good at
all because if they're going to go
westwards towards slavigans the only two
places that really matter in the donbass
those are the places you get slavians
coming to us you get the donbass if you
fail to get those then you'll never take
the donbass there aren't many roads in
the area there are only two roads there
are four and the uh the what was the the
mo4 as it was called I think it's now
called the E40 in the local uh numbers
so there's only two roads the the fields
either side of the road are wet and
muddy so armor can only go up the roads
and if they do that the ukrainians will
pick them off and then look at the
ground in between first of all I mean
that ground is rising all the time it's
lots of natural defensive positions and
the ukrainians will certainly defend
that ground so if the Russians wanted to
move Westward from back mode they will
have to fight every inch of the way
toward the fortresses that the
ukrainians will make of slaving ants and
crematories so if Batman Falls
militarily it won't do the Russians a
whole lot of good if they're going to
take salvation they'll have to take them
from the north and from the South not
from the East and from what we've seen
the Russians haven't got the capability
to do that not just because of the
conditions you were describing and the
geography not only have they not got the
capability but every time they've taken
a place like severeign they stop they
can't keep going and so they will there
will be even if they take back much I
can almost guarantee there'll be an
operational pause as they call it while
they they take breath and and sort
themselves out for two or three or maybe
four weeks they're never able to take a
position and keep going keep the enemy
off balance they just can't do it but
symbolically it would be important yeah
it's another place to fall to Russia
politically if they lose it kieva's
really got to manage the loss of this
place militarily they shouldn't worry
too much okay all right Michael thank
you um Professor Michael Clark remember
the analysis from Ukraine uh we'll talk
again later on in the program